Two rival
rulings on medical abortion
pills came down yesterday,
the first from Texas,
a federal judge
ruling to suspend the FDA's two decade
old approval of MS. Firestone.
Then just 2 hours later,
a federal judge in Washington
state ruling
that FDA must
keep the medication abortion
on the shelves.
In 17 Democratic states
and the District of Columbia.
President Biden
is vowing to fight this ruling.
The DOJ and the FDA have already filed
separate appeals.
Vice President
Harris told reporters Friday night
that courts should not be allowed
to tell the FDA what it can do.
This is a drug that the FDA approved
as safe might be years ago
and has been proven to be safe
for 20 years.
So this is a dangerous precedent.
Mifepristone is part of the
most common abortion method in the US.
Data from hundreds of studies
have shown that it is highly safe
and effective.
Its safety is on par
with common
over-the-counter pain relievers
like ibuprofen and acetaminophen.
We're joined now
by CNN's Elizabeth Cohen.
Explain how widely this is used and talk
more about the safety
Right, Victor.
It's been used very widely
and it is very safe.
I think a lot of people don't know
that actually
there are more abortions done now
with the pills than done surgically.
Let's take a look at how
that's increased over the years.
So since 20, 20,
it's gone up and up
and up to the point now
where more than 53% of abortions
in the U.S.
are done with pills
or medication abortions.
And let's take a look
at some of the side effects.
You know, drugs have side effects
when we look at deadly side effects
for every million women
who have used math for Princeton.
There have been 20 deaths.
If you look at penicillin
if you look at Viagra
it's many more for penicillin
it's 20 deaths per million users.
For Viagra it's 49 deaths
per million users.
So actually
when you look at deadly side effects,
the first stone is safer
than many other drugs,
not just these two.
Victor and Elizabeth,
could you talk about
how this ruling
could have long term impacts
on the trust in the FDA approval process?
Yes, there is a lot
of trust in the FDA approval process.
It has been there for many, many decades.
And other countries besides the U.S.
also rely on it
because it is a good process.
It is rigorous.
And so drug companies
apply the
there's a team of scientists
or teams of scientists
at the FDA
and outside advisers who weigh in
on whether or not it should be approved.
And here, one judge
all by his lonesome has said, now,
I disagree with all of those experts.
I don't think this drug
should be on the market.
So you can imagine the drug companies
when they hear this think, wait a second,
are we going to invest
millions of dollars
in drugs, in life saving drugs?
If a single judge can just say,
now that needs to come off the market,
that is problematic for drug development
and that affects all of us.
Sure does.
Elizabeth Cohen,
appreciate your reporting.
Thank you very much.
Emergency physician
and deputy dean
at Brown University
School of Public Health, Dr.
Megan Ranney, joining us now.
Dr.
I mean,
this is the most common
abortion method
in the U.S.,
as we just heard
Elizabeth Cohen report there.
First off,
I just want to get your reaction
to this ruling
I am flabbergasted by this ruling
for a judge who has no scientific
training to overturn a panel of experts
who advise the FDA
on the safety
and efficacy of a medication
is frankly unprecedented.
Not only was this medication approved
23, almost 23 years ago,
but it's also undergone
incredibly rigorous safety monitoring
since then.
It is part of a
special monitoring program
that is applied to only a handful
of medications
across the United States,
recognizing that this is a medication
that is unfortunately subjected
to some political debate.
And let me be clear,
as Elizabeth outlined,
the medication is tremendously safe.
It is actually far safer
to have a medication abortion
than to undergo childbirth
in terms of the likelihood of severe
effects on the body and hospitalization.
We don't know
ultimately what will happen
with this ruling
because as we
know, appeals are now underway.
And this
ruling that puts a pause
on this particular
medication abortion pill does not take
effect, are not expected to take effect
until about a week from now.
But in terms of the confusion
that this is going to cause,
let's start from the doctors then
and the providers.
And I mean,
I guess
there might be a scramble now to find
a different medication
This is certainly
something that has been under discussion
for months.
Among those who do provide
medication, abortions
for today
in states
where medication abortion is legal.
Nothing changes.
But we are waiting to see what happens
next.
At this point, the FDA has said
this is still a
safe and efficacious medication.
So for folks
that are have an appointment,
still show up for your appointment
for doctors
who are planning to prescribe,
they are getting guidance
from the American College
of Obstetrics
and Gynecology,
from the American Association
of Family Physicians
and from other specialty societies
that help us decide
kind of what
the right next thing to do
is for our patients
in the context of these
conflicting legal rulings.
We are not lawyers. Right.
We're doctor. Right. Right.
Our goal is to take care of our clients.
Sure. Sure.
And for today,
we're going to be just looking.
And, you know, the judge in Texas
in his ruling said that the FDA.
27 years ago
improperly or improperly approved
this abortion pill.
And that you know,
he had taken into account
or the FDA has not taken into account
the physiological effects
that taking this drug has on women.
What do you say to that?
The physiological effects of misoprostol
and misoprostol,
the two medications
that go into this medication, abortion,
are essentially
the same as the physiological effects
of a miscarriage.
So many,
many women have had miscarriages.
It is not a pleasant experience,
but it is not inherently unsafe.
The judge also alleged
that there were psychological effects
from these medications.
Let me be very clear.
There are more than 50 years of studies
showing that
the psychological effects of abortion
are nil.
What effects
women's mental health is being forced
to carry a pregnancy to term?
The availability of safe
and legal abortion is a strong protection
to women's mental health And lastly,
because as I read,
mifepristone is typically
used in combination
with another drug
that you just mentioned, misoprostol,
that is still available on the market
so do you think the alternative could be
just using misoprostol
for those
who need a medication, abortion?
And let's say, you know,
this pause continues
or should this continue?
Yes.
Using misoprostol
alone is certainly an option,
but it is less effective
and associated
with a higher number of side effects.
The combination of the two medications,
the reason we give them together
is because they work and they're safe.
So it would be a shame
for the women of America
if they have to resort to
a single medication regimen
that is less effective
than what they currently have access to.